thanks for joining me this afternoon
um it's it's nice to be back doing these
in person I'm going to hope that I
remember how to use the clicker that
I've got in my hand I've been practicing
for the last 15 minutes because I'm used
to just like you actually are sitting at
the keyboard but this is so far away I
forgot what lecterns are like for a tall
person it's like it's gonna be really
awkward because I have a like when I'm
doing some live coding I'm going to be
just hunched over and but we'll make it
work
um and it's coming to the end of the
first day of NDC Melbourne
um so thanks for joining me uh and I
hope you've been enjoying the conference
so far
my name's Aaron Powell and I work for
Microsoft as part of the developer
advocacy team or the cloud advocacy team
I should I I've got to get better at
saying that we're Cloud Advocates not
developer Advocates because we have it
pros and Power Platform Advocates and
people of that nature so we're not just
developers we're covering all the things
that we do but I'm of a developer
background I've been doing web
development for uh
long enough that I'm not going to admit
it properly on stage because I know this
is being recorded but long enough to
have seen quite a lot of changes in the
industry
um I've I've had the the pleasure of
working with a large number of different
text editors over that time and that's
why I I wanted to do a talk about vs
code because it's the one that I'm
loving the most at the moment but I've
used everything from vim and emacs Jed
for like old school Unix people I've
been that's that's kind of where I
started Pico and Nano those are the
editors that I use the university
because there was modern technology back
then oh wait no I am now starting to
date myself all the way through things
like Sublime atom and visual studio the
full edition and obviously more recently
vs code and
um because my because a lot of what I do
is is web development like vs code
really fits into that sort of space and
and the the kinds of things that I'm
doing and I I like it is an editor if
you want to reach out to me or follow me
on social media those are my contact
details my if you've got any questions
that you don't want to ask at the
conference or or get caught on video
asking me um shoot me an email or send
me a DM on Twitter um whatever the case
may be I want to make sure that I can
answer as many questions as I can so
that you get the most out of the content
that that I've got today but
you're not just here to you know less
than 60 Minutes of me talk about you
know myself and my social media presence
and how amazing that is as much as you
know I'd like to talk about myself for
60 minutes it's not really why you're
here and we're here to talk about vs
code and and I I think it is the most
powerful editor that we've got at the
moment
whether you're new to the software
industry and like you you're just like
coming out of a boot camp or just
finishing University or uh or
cross-skilling um or you've been using
editors for as many years as I have
um I I think that there's going to be
something in this talk for you
um I I don't profess to know everything
that you can do with vs code but I'm
going to show off some of the things
that I think are the best features of it
and and some of the the hidden gems that
people have within uh the people who
don't necessarily know about within vs
code but to get started I just want to
make sure that everyone is familiar
enough with vs code so I said I I know
there's people out there that they're
just getting started in the industry and
they might not have had much time with a
software like this so I just want to
make sure that we're all on the same
page and also the terminology that I use
to describe things
um does actually make sense because I
think I know all the things correctly
but I will probably mislabel something
so uh you'll know when when I say
something like well I've never heard of
that and then yeah this is so this is a
lap around like a very quick lap around
vs code so
this is the the editor um for anyone
that hasn't seen it
um I I've just opened one of my
oversource projects
um using a remote extension and this is
showing obviously a chunk of HTML but
let's break down the stuff that's in the
editor so across the top we've got this
uh the the title bar and pretty much
every windowed application has one of
them it's got our menu system and file
edit etc etc but it's also got some
contextual information about where I am
the folder that I've got open the file
that I've got open the status of that
file whether it's got whether it's a
dirty file so I've got unsaved changes
against it things like that
um but that's entirely customizable like
if you want to put some emojis in there
because you just love having emojis in
every aspect of your life you can edit
the the way that the the state the title
bar is going to appear in vs code
because it's like it's customizable to
make it the editor that you want it to
be
we've then got our sidebar on the left
hand side well
yes you're like yeah I'm not I'm not
used to actually seeing the people I'm
like what the screen's flipped because
no no it is yes it is the left I'm I'm
going to do that a bunch I reckon
because I'm just like I don't my brain
doesn't know where things are at the
minute
um and this this Explorer will uh show
you all the sorts of things that um like
your file structure your file structure
which is what it's defaulted to there
it's where we get to our debunking
information so if we're sending break
points and
um putting watch variables because we're
debugging the project we get to
extensions extensions can add to this um
sidebar on the side I've got a couple of
extensions there such as Azure Docker
and a couple others that we'll have a
look at a little bit later
then across the bottom uh we have uh
just like generic information about the
editor that other extensions have jumped
in and put there so in the bottom
left-hand corner it says WSL Ubuntu
because this example was opened from a
remote extension against WSL so I'm
working on Windows but I'm actually
doing all my development in Linux I
actually don't do any development on
Windows but I run Windows as my primary
operating system it's all done through
WSL or wsl2 more accurately and then
other expression what git Branch I'm on
are there any errors or Warnings
um what account that I'm signed in as
all the way through to like the line
endings the file language that's being
picked up and again this stuff you can
turn off so if you're someone that might
have
um has some neurodiversities around
attention deficit you can turn off some
of this stuff because you know maybe
that's too much information and you're
like oh why what's it what's it telling
me in the about errors or what's it
telling me about the the file encodings
why is that changing you can customize
that to make it work for the the kinds
of workflows that you've got gone
and then I've got the terminal popped
open here this is in uh it's probably
the bash terminal because I'm on a Linux
environment uh you know it's just a it's
a it's a terminal
um I can execute commands I tend to use
I I run my uh git from a command line so
I'll do all that from through there
rather than the git extension built into
vs code run npm to do the npme things
and all that kind of stuff and we can
have as many terminals as we want open
it's also got this is where we get to
like errors and warnings so if you've
got like a linter running or it's a
compiled language project so you're not
writing JavaScript
um it'll give you like errors about the
the compiler State because you've you
know you've missed a semicolon somewhere
or you haven't closed the parentheses or
whatever the case may be debug output if
you're running in debug mode
or that kind of stuff
um and then we actually have like we
have an editor surface
so like there's a whole bunch of stuff I
told you about vs code that's there but
it's also a text editor like amazing
there's a there's a place where you can
go and edit a file uh this is a HTML
file syntax filing again like all the
kinds of things you expect from a modern
text Data stuff
and lastly on the side we have uh the
mini map so this is like a thousand foot
view of uh the code file that you've got
open this is obviously a fairly short
code file so it's only bunched up in the
top but if you had like a 10 000 line
code file you can use that to quickly
navigate up and down at a very large
file I mean not that anyone would have
like a 10 000 line code file like no no
like I've I've never worked on projects
that have got 10 000 lines of JavaScript
or anything like that no that that's bad
don't don't do that
okay so now that uh oh you yeah oh yeah
so feel free to shout out questions at
any point in time um so yes I see one
just back there
ah yes
excellent so um just for the for the
recording and for anyone that didn't
hear down the back
um vs code it's great for opening files
that are large um and yeah a good
example is a log file that it's an
enormous file um and it will it will
offer to open it in a mode to be Memory
optimized for dealing with large files I
mean I think it essentially does a
chunked read of that file so yeah you're
not actually trying to load two gigs of
like log file into memory and then
accidentally syntax highlighted because
it goes oh maybe that's markdown you're
like no no no no no it's definitely not
um and yeah so it it will be it will um
optimize for that kind of stuff so yeah
um it's a it's a good um good tip and uh
one that I'm going to steal for next
time I do this presentation
thank you
all right so uh I'm I'm a keyboard
person like I
I don't tend to use the mouse much like
before the pandemic at least I was
predominantly on a laptop so I had a
touchpad and anyone that spent extended
periods of time with just a touchpad
knows that you're not using a touchpad
you're either going to buy an external
mouse or you're just going to learn
every single cable shortcut that you can
and that's what I kind of set myself out
to do so I
um I I use as many keyboard shortcuts as
I can and I find that's a for my
workflows that's a really good way to be
productive in in vs code so
let's kill slides for a moment and
actually jump over to vs code and let me
find the right vs code instance because
they've got like a heap of them open
here now demos demos will take a a
variety of instances so I've got them
all open feel free to refold in the
notes and then just doze off while I go
while I read through them and go through
them they are there on the screen but if
there is only one keyboard shortcut that
you ever learned from vs code it is
control P I'm on Windows if you're on
Mac or have a different keyboard layout
it will I think Mac is command I I'm not
sure it's been a long time since I've
used a Mac but control control P brings
up the command palette Ctrl shift p
brings up oops Ctrl shift p brings up
the
um uh the like the the actions list so
this is all the things that you can do
with Insider vs code from menus from
like right click actions from extensions
and things that actually don't have
anywhere else that you can get to them
except via VIA this section and the
first thing I'm going to turn on is
screencast mode so screencast oh yep
yeah so so command p is um like the the
base point and then there's a bunch of
things you could do off that one of them
if you put a uh greater than symbol it
goes into the like the actions list
which is what we had there so if I go to
control p and then a greater than sign I
then get that filter down list
uh so from here this is default to like
a file Searcher so I can type in um yeah
like read me and I can find a readme
file but then if I was to put in
question mark it would show me all the
other things that I can do off of here
so it's like a primitive help if I do
like an ad symbol I can find symbols
within files uh hash to get go to line
and stuff like that most people do
remember
um uh Ctrl shift p because that drops
into the actions but I always start with
Ctrl P because from there you can then
build onto it to get to this list of
actions uh these lists of things you can
do or you can do a variety of other
things
um so yeah a good good question like um
and explain the differences there so I
turned on screencast mode uh and I find
this is a really useful tool when you're
doing pair programming particularly if
you're doing it like over a screen share
or something like that because what it
does is every key press that you do is
then going to appear you've probably
seen that flashing up as I've started
typing so like if I was to do screencast
you'll see that those keys those
characters start appearing I'll leave it
on for the duration of this presentation
so as I do keyboard shortcuts you can
see what they are in case they forget to
describe what they are uh or or say what
they are as they're doing it but yeah
this is a just a useful tool um
particularly if you're doing some pair
programming so that the person that
you're pairing with can see what you're
doing uh from that with screencast mode
in settings
we'll go to the settings UI we can
actually configure that because it is
like you can see every character that
I'm doing there cast screen cast we can
adjust some information about that and
we can also change the keys uh that it's
uh that are appearing so if you only
want like the command key so um Control
Alt shift that kind of stuff um so you
can filter it down so maybe it's not
verbose like if you if you've got it
turned on and running code it's like
just spewing out constantly because yeah
like everything you're doing um but yeah
good a good little tip um for if you're
doing uh presentations or if you're
doing uh work where you've got other
people that will need to see your screen
but they maybe can't see your keyboard
or if you don't want them like hovering
right over the top of your shoulder
so yes uh to um to the question before
about you know control P versus control
shift p um yeah this brings up a whole
bunch of uh this is the entry point
where you can do everything so yeah
greater than symbol comes into here
um if we were to do the uh at symbol
this will find uh symbols across the uh
entire
um uh
uh like folders set of folders that
we've got open so I'm I'm in a thing
with a bunch of markdown files so it's
actually just bringing up markdown
headings uh but if I was to jump to
another project that I've got here uh so
this is not the project I wanted
as I said I've got a lot of vs code
instances that one there okay control p
and then at now this is going to find uh
symbols inside of an F sharp project
here because I have to oh sorry that's
in add is the current file uh
uh amp send no uh I've forgotten it off
already uh question mark if we want
symbols in the workspace is Hash that's
it so symbols in the entire workspace
um so this will then as I start typing
so I start typing family uh and it
doesn't find my F sharp code
yay
I'm like contractually obliged to show F
sharp in uh in a demo and this one has
failed ah there we go
uh person no
people damn it I can't even I can't even
find something oh program
there we go found something yay I
demonstrated that a thing can work the
way that I described it would work
um yeah so so this is like if you're
working in something that has a like
some form of a type system or is
exposing something that it pretends to
be a type system so like markdown files
um if you're working in yeah like a
repository that has markdown files you
can use symbol finding to go through to
the various headings
um so like CSS you can use that to
navigate through the um the CSS file to
the selectors that you've got with
inside of that if you're in a stronger
type language like a c-sharp project or
F sharp project or
um golang typescript Etc you can then go
through the symbols of those files
but we'll come back to the
one of these other workspaces that I've
got here okay um so off uh control p uh
other things we can get to if I type
term
t-e-i-m this is how I can interact with
the terminals that I've got I don't have
any journals open so I'll just hit enter
to create a new terminal and then Ctrl P
term
we'll see that I have the uh the first
one there is the terminal that I just
created and create another terminal
and now I can navigate between those
just from some key presses but they're
all called zsh because that's the shell
that has popped so I don't actually know
what they are so I can do Ctrl shift p
terminal and I can actually rename the
terminal that I've currently if I find
that term
rename there we go and let's call this
npm
so now if I go Ctrl P term npm I can get
to the right terminal that I want to
open so if I let's say that I was
building on a project that had like a a
front-end and a back end in the same
repository so maybe I've run like an MTM
start script in both those locations I
could then name the terminal as front
end and back end so then I can I know
which one I can jump to so I can look at
the correct set of log files so yeah
that like that's a useful one if you've
got a lot of terminals open at the same
time renaming them just makes it easier
to find and it will fuzzy matches you
type into the uh into the command
palette that's appeared up the top
all right there's actually nothing no
code to run in here so we'll close out
the terminal
um the last one is that I just want to
show off is View
so this is how we can interact with the
um the the sidebar which I've actually
got collapsed at the moment Ctrl B
expand that out Ctrl B to collapse at
the end
um I also have that on the right hand
side instead of the left hand side and
that's not just because I am a reformed
Visual Studio developer where everything
was defaulted to the right I actually
find having the status so the the
sidebar on the right hand side more uh
better than the left because if I'm
opening and closing it so oftentimes if
I've got multiple windows open
um you start kind of running out of
screen real estate if it's on the left
oh let me illustrate this just right
click and move to the left
the
Center of focus now shifts every time
the sidebar pops in and out because
you're actually changing where the left
margin is within side of our editor
that's why I like to have mine on the
right it means that
I can easily open and close it and it's
not going to annoy you as the audience
watching this talk and when I'm doing
development it doesn't annoy me because
it doesn't annoy me and no one else has
to care uh anyway sorry uh we're doing a
view so view gives us access to
everything that's within the sidebar
sidebar I'm just
my camera was always it was that side
it's there floating the world
um so I can get to like explore research
Etc but I can also get to the sub
sections of that so let's go to say the
uh like the outline view
um that's just popped up at the bottom
of the uh the Explorer window there and
that's the outline of the markdown
headings that I have with inside of this
file and that set focus on there that um
that I can navigate through that and
jump up and down the headings so again
more stuff that we can just do Straight
off the the keyboard that gives us
access to a particular bit of context
within vs code without having to you
know use the mouse to navigate back and
forth between all this stuff
all right
um like most editors and you know bits
of software it's it's highly
configurable in terms of like font size
and all that sort of stuff I've got this
zoomed in
um uh just like the entire editor is
zoomed in so you can see everything not
just the text being increased um be
aware that if you are increasing font
size and then you zoom the editor in the
uh the text will then be magnified
because you're actually magnifying the
entire editor itself that one catches me
out a little bit
um yeah uh pretty much you know that's
customizable to look and feel and
operate exactly the way that you want it
to work
uh
if if you want to get to the cable truck
and there's like so many keyboard
shortcuts to memorize control KZ oh
sorry
um I'll come back to shortcuts I want to
talk uh it was actually Zen mode which
was coming up next so got a lovely big
4k monitor at home
um and I want to hide everything else
and have as much real estate available
for you know the thing that I'm
potentially working on at this point in
time Zen mode control KZ
um Pops that up there it's removed like
the the stuff around the like the editor
that you maybe don't need to look at all
the time like the status bar is gone
sidebar is like completely disabled and
all that sort of stuff I just have a
text editor with you know the line
numbers like and the current file like I
don't even see what other files are open
you know control tab obviously gets
through all of that
um with Zen mode you can then modify the
settings that it has so if we go Ctrl P
control shift p
settings
and then Zen mode we can choose what
things are going to be there it's like
actually I don't even want line numbers
um only problem is that you've got to go
in and out of Zen mode to have that take
effect but now we've got rid of our line
numbers simplified something down here
again this could be useful for someone
that uh yeah like has attention
attention issues and just wants to get
themselves like focused properly in what
they're doing so yeah and you can
configure like the the width and uh and
stuff of the the editor surface uh all
that all without settings
let's drop back at us there is Zen mode
and
keep trucking on through all right uh
speaking of settings so most of the
settings are accessible via controlled
comma and that will get you to the UI
version of the settings but not
everything can could be can be
configured there some settings require
complex objects to be provided to them
one such is editor rules so we could get
to that by doing settings
settings settings
and then going to the the Json file so
this is like the raw view of all the
settings you can see I've got I've got a
lot of things that I've customized in my
vs code I'm going to just just go right
to the very bottom and find something
that I've previously commented out
editor rules uh which is missing us I'm
missing a comma let's put that back in
So editor rules are used to insert
guidelines with inside the text editor
at particular margin points so uh I've
popped that in there and it's a little
bit zoomed in so maybe I'll just change
the size of these let's go to 40 and 80.
and see there's where it starts getting
annoying because now I'm like every
character press is appearing for me on
screen
okay so I put in some editor guides that
kind of indicates that it indicates the
character width that um within the
screen now I I don't know how many
people came from working on like old
terminal programs where you had an 80
character like hard width
um and like you didn't make lines that
were longer than 80 characters because
you didn't have side scrolling and that
was literally the width of the number of
characters you could display on your
screen
um and I I know a lot of Open Source
projects that still love to maintain
that 80 width um characters and I don't
quite understand why but cool beans so
if we've got like this 4k monitor like
why would I want to limit it to this
much of the screen
having having like my useful text editor
area well one of the reasons why you
might want to put in guidelines like
this is if you're working with people
that are visually impaired they might be
running at a resolution
um completely different to what you're
running you know to to increase the font
size or to increase their exercise so
that they can read the the same code
that you're working on and having
something that is 200 characters across
means that they're going to be
constantly scrolling back and forth
because they they require the additional
um the additional font size or the
additional Zoom levels on their screen
so having this can help just make a bit
more of an accessible code base because
you're you're more aware of limitations
that other people with inside of your
teams might have or you yourself um if
if you're in that situation so that's
that's kind of a use case that um that I
can see for editor guidelines I mean
other people will have other use cases
no doubt maybe they are still building
for you know 80 character width
terminals but yeah that's something
that's there you can modify my color and
column width so you can have as and you
can have as many of these as you want
and you can just rainbow it across one
uh one column character at a time if you
so desire
um
I probably wouldn't do that personally
oops uh uh let's just comment that out
okay KC KC not k k c is to insert
comments in the language that you're
currently in KU is to uncomment in the
language that you're currently in so
um that's what that's that uh one that I
was doing there all right and
another one that I didn't find out until
I started writing this talk and
researching some of the the more nuanced
things you can do in uh in vs code is uh
code action's on Save
so I I have my editor set up so that it
auto saves um after a delay timeout so
that I don't actually have to remember
to hit Ctrl s it's just like it's
working a you know a cloud connected
editor I don't actually have to hit save
and at some point the little floppy disk
icon in my computer will go away because
it just always is saving but there are
other things you can do on Save and one
of those is code is um is run a code
action and let's do that by modifying my
JavaScript uh so uh this is my
JavaScript language profile at the top I
have language profiles for a variety of
different languages that's indicated by
the square brackets and the language
moniker there so JavaScript Json C Json
typescript react etc etc and this is
something you have to do from the Json
settings you can't do this through the
UI so we're going to enter and put in a
code actions on Save
and then we will see what what can we do
well one of the things we could do is
organize Imports
and we'll set that to true
so that if I come to
Javascript file over here
um and let's say that I've got a
LinkedIn rule uh in my in my code base
that says that I want to have I have to
alphabetize the the using statements or
the import statements in the JavaScript
case control s and that's done that for
me I can just import everything in
whatever order that I want and then hit
Ctrl s and let's reordered them to match
the linting rules that we've got with
inside of our application
not a huge thing like this is something
that's available
um that I can do control shift p and
then do organize Imports
but I can just have it on save like it's
just it's one of those things that now I
don't have to think about it just it
happens for me
um and it's and I that's the power I
find with uh with editor customizations
like this is you start doing things that
you don't have to commit to muscle
memory or you don't have to remember to
do it just does them for you and you it
it just
um removes one of those paper cuts that
you might have in your life
but I'm going to remove that setting
because otherwise I will forget that
it's there and be very confused when I
open a project and hit s control save
and I've got a new huge uh commit that I
have to do I'm like I didn't touch the
import statements
um
so from in terms of like you know
messing around with the editor that's
that's one of my favorite um additions
uh let's just do a quick thing on a
quick look at some keyboard shortcuts
the these are like the keyboard
shortcuts that I think everyone needs to
know when working with vs code so we've
seen control uh control p uh to bring up
the command palette um if we want to get
to the settings so before control
control comma
um if we're working in a well a language
that actually is a programming language
not markdown uh we might get uh some
code actions provided to us so let me
see if I can I should be able to do that
in one of these files over here
uh not that file because that file has a
lot of errors and we're going to ignore
those
let's say that that I I want to turn
this into a local variable you'll see
there's a little light bulb that's
appeared just underneath the return on
line 20. to access that light bulb
control Dot
and then this brings up a bunch of code
actions um here's some quick
refactorings so
I can extract that out to a new function
so control dot that's how you trigger
off that light bulb so having to Mouse
over and click it
uh another so that's another another
good one to commit to muscle memory
uh duplicating lines
alt shift up
puts a new line above and that moves
your cursor up Ctrl shift down
puts a new line down moves your cursor
to that
uh if we want to do like a multi if we
want to do a multi-character select
uh control shift uh and then the drill
so Ctrl shift Alt and the direction that
we want to expand our cursor
up and down
and then once we've got that cursor like
control and now I can do a box selection
across so that's just doing box
selection based off of the words
on a larger screen
um I'll often have multiple files open
side by side control forward slash uh
we'll pop that over open to the side and
you can do that again and again and
again and we can end up with a lot of
open editors and that's becoming really
hard you can also there isn't a keyboard
shortcut by default but we can do a
split oops if I can type split so split
edit it down so we can do vertical as
well as horizontal splitting I have two
vertical monitors so I use down splits
as well so that I can have stacked files
instead of just side by side files files
and the only thing that annoys me about
doing splits like this is that it takes
the current file open and puts that
there and leaves it so now I have two
copies of this markdown file open yeah
not quite sure what that's useful for
but that's the way it works
um okay if you want to navigate between
editor groups that you've got open
control 1 control 2 control n for the
edge of the group so Ctrl two pop back
there close off that bottom split
uh Ctrl D the nautical thing that you
want to find uh let's let's control d uh
we'll select the next of the next
instance of whatever you've got selected
so in this case let's select the word
split and then it selects that so now
I've got a potentially multiple multiple
multi-character selection actually we'll
use control we go control D and then now
we've got multiple characters all over
that file so I could say that I want
that lowercase so TRL
multiple selects like that
um and there's a heat more key Bindings
that I'm not going to cover off today
but you can get that by going to control
K control r
and that'll open up the key binding
reference for the operating system that
you're currently on so obviously this is
land on the Windows one and you can see
that well only got about 30 minutes left
um I'm not going to cover off all of
that because you can see how many there
are and that's not even very well zoomed
in
all right
uh Anya I have a couple other just um
small ones there like uh old first well
up and down top of the the current line
up and down um you can like and you can
use that off a multi-line selection so I
can move like chunks of code
um you know good for like quick
refactorings and things like that uh
control up and down
um moves the editor window so uh does
that you know scrolling without you
actually having to jump in and scroll uh
and the last one that I have not been
able to commit to memory because I
always I every time I go to use it I'm
like what is it Ctrl shift p control k v
markdown preview
like if you're ever working on docs
control side by side markdown preview
I'm like ah why can I never remember
that one I can remember all these other
obscure ones but I can't remember how to
open my game preview and I do a I write
a lot of markdown files and that's the
one that I really really wish I could
remember
but okay back to PowerPoint because
that's that's enough like you know
actually you know showing something
that's not a PowerPoint deck it's this
is still a technical presentation we've
got to be in PowerPoint I am an advocate
after all
uh I know there's at least one other
advocate in this room and they're
hanging ahead in shame
um coach divots uh coach divots uh one
of my favorite ways to do demos uh live
coding demos because you're not here to
watch me actually try and type out large
chunks of code I'm going to forget that
I'm going to make a mistake and someone
in the back is gonna go
there's an error and I know what it is
they're gonna get a problem and then I
want to be the one that tells them
um so use it I use code Snippets to
cheat by just rewriting prewriting the
code and type it like a little uh
snippet like step one step two so I know
where I'm up to hit enter and boom hold
on a bunch of code appears but that's
great if you're doing presentations but
like Snippets can be useful for
obviously anything that you're doing
um and Snippets can be used it can be
set up with inside of your system so if
you've got common things you're doing
across like all your projects you're
commonly working on multiple like react
projects you might have react Snippets
but you can also embed them inside of a
single git repo for or inside the the
repository for that project that you're
on we do that with a DOT vs file uh
sorry dot vs code folder which I've got
right up there in the the top we can put
Snippets in there and then they're part
of that repo so this is a way that you
could have things that are for a
specific project so you've got a maybe a
particular pattern for the way your of
working with creating classes or the way
that you want to work with a react
component or whatever the case may be
you can set Snippets they can be part of
that code base so whenever someone opens
up that in vs code
they've already got the coding
conventions that you have in your
project ready for them um to go you
don't have to tell them then go install
all this other additional stuff starting
to put more of the contextual things for
a project with inside of that location
the other problem is that particularly
if you're doing a multi-line snippet
well it's uh let me show you what it
looks like
it's like that it is really tedious to
ride particularly because you've got to
put in like line breaks and escapes and
and all that kind of stuff well
I I came across this website called uh
snippet generator.app where we can
generate code Snippets for vs code or
sublime or
they're probably going to have to remove
Adam at some point oh poor atom
uh if anyone wasn't aware Adam it's kind
of the precursor to vs code it was it
was github's first major editor and they
uh it died like last week or something
like that so yeah poor vs Paul Adam not
vs code that's not dead yet so let's go
import react
react from see this is why I don't like
writing code uh because you've seen how
many errors I've just done there and
that will be export uh const and we
would control I because I want something
that I can change and we'll call this
component
and that will just be a react component
and then we'll just have it linked to a
H1
hi NDC Melbourne
we're leaving that spelling mistake in
there because I'm too lazy to go back
and fix it cool and that generated me my
code snippet there on the side there or
at least the the body of that code
snippet I would go then and fill in the
the language that it's going to be
attached to and all that kind of stuff
this is just so much easier you could
you know grab code out of your existing
project because you want to make that as
a reusable snippet that anyone can use
come and paste it in there gives you the
snippet body instead of you having to go
okay the start of every line is going to
quite the end of everyone's going to
need a quote I'm going to need a comma
on all except for the the last one yeah
something like this
um a useful little tool to get started
extensions vs code is actually a really
simple editor when you first install it
it doesn't do a whole lot it it
understands some basic programming
language syntax highlighting like
JavaScript and HTML and a few things
like that but the real power of vs code
is extensions and I'm sure that anyone
that's using vs code has their favorite
set of extensions that they're
installing everywhere so I just want to
kind of show off a couple of extensions
that
I include anytime I set up a new machine
and or anytime I set up a project with
um with vs code these are the extensions
that I will always have
um and they're going to pop in in a
random order because that's the way I
set my animation up cool beans
um editor config edit config uh enforce
consistent style guide across your
entire
um across that workspace that you've got
open like how many characters are you
indenting uh White space
um for for each line like what's like
how you know how much does a tab are you
using tabs spaces you can solve this
problem with an editor config by
enforcing it at a vs code level every
time that person hits tab editor config
will say well you've said it's got to be
spaces so actually we're putting in four
spaces
um if you're working with the.net
project
um uh c-sharp language engine or like
formatting engine supports editor config
and you can extend that with c-sharp
idea isms but also things like you know
what line innings are we having I was
working with someone the other day and
they were having a problem opening bash
files that
um that I'd created because I'd created
them in uh cells they had Linux line
endings they I hadn't put git attributes
they cleaned it on Windows and it had
crlf everywhere and they were then
trying to run it in Docker and it didn't
work so you can use something like
editor config to enforce that if you're
doing stuff with GitHub GitHub pull
requests and issues is kind of a must
have that allows you to do ever like
everything you need to do from get with
GitHub with inside of uh well uh sorry
Works pull requests and issues with
inside of vs code let me see if I can
find the right editor here we go so I've
got that installed in this editor here
if I pop that open I actually have an
outstanding pull request here so I can
double click on that one
I can right click on that and open oh
not open on GitHub
well isn't it opening when I click on it
oh anyway
um I can see
I'm not going to fiddle with that but
you can see what files were changed
within it I can uh so I've got access to
all that there I can say pull requests
that I've made I've been tagged on and
all that kind of stuff there I can
create new GitHub issues where this can
become really useful is if you're using
this with the to-do highlight
extension so that will help you find to
do items with inside of your your
workspace so it just looks for code
comments though like like whack whack to
do so you can select that and then using
the GitHub pull request extension turn
that straight into a GitHub issue
because every time we put a to-do in
there we totally come back and fix that
at some point in our in our project's
life cycle don't we
yeah I'm seeing a lot of a lot of people
actually knowing of that one a lot more
than I would expect
uh
rest quiet
any project that's doing HTTP uh
endpoints with inside of it uh that you
you know particularly if you're doing it
as like a single page application where
you are just going to be calling those
from like a react or like some kind of
JavaScript application
um rest client allows you to execute and
the kinds of things you do with Postman
or Insomniac or anything like that but
you write a a file that you would then
commit as part of that git repo so now
again it's not doing something that you
don't already have tools that are
capable of doing but it's bringing it
closer to the code you don't have to
make sure you install Postman make sure
you um get the postman collection import
that collection so you can execute them
um it just becomes another file within
your git repo that you can open in and
then execute a HTTP request straight
from there if you're doing graphql
there's a is capable of doing graphql as
well as as normal HTTP calls
code spell checker I am a question or
comment
oh yeah so yeah every economy was every
every QA that you know sees race client
stops using Postman um and yeah because
it just it's incredibly simple to use
um but also has all the power that you
get out of any of those other tools
um and yeah like I said it's capable of
doing
um graphical if that's the the platform
that you're doing if you want to learn
more about graphql come to my session
tomorrow afternoon
spell checker um I am a horrendous
speller uh so I I I remember a project
um back probably 10 years ago uh we'll
we're building a database for a custom
CRM and we had uh we had to track um a
person named a person name changes so we
created a table code called person name
history
so we thought it was actually a person
named his Troy
we didn't find out until a few months
later at this point all the code was
working against a person named his Troy
and it was way too much effort to go
back and and refactor so we literally
shipped a database table called person
name history and all like we had classes
that were generally generated from that
if we had code spell checker we probably
would have got told the error was there
and just still ignored it but it would
have told us it was there and we would
have gone ah I'll I'll put it to do to
fix that later on
I I'm and the other one that I've got on
there is peacock
um uh peacock was written by a colleague
of mine at Microsoft and what it does is
it it allows you to change like the the
shell frame color in vs code so if
you've got a couple of different vs code
windows open like I do at the moment um
you can have them colored differently so
you can know which ones which
um yeah useful if you maybe your back
end and your Frontier in a separate uh
folders so you can navigate between
those uh quite easily
uh if you're a.net developer I I might
have partially left this in there
because we've had a controversial week
around.net development in vs code but
there is a c-sharp extension for vs code
that is look it's not visual studio
um it's decent enough it'll get you uh
like I I use it because it gets me most
of the way there
um in the sorts of things that I need
it'll find symbols it'll um it'll have
uh has integration so you can do like
Ctrl shift B to build and all that kind
of stuff
um but the the visual studio tooling
team has announced that there is going
to be a new extension coming out that
will uh address some of the challenges
that the c-sharp extension already
currently has
um for like the one person that is
either in the room or watching on the
video
um ionide is like the F sharp extension
to use it is actually the best F-sharp
uh extension that I've ever used uh also
have every experience I've ever used
I've been doing F sharp for
uh over a decade now and yeah it's like
I I couldn't not use it anymore
um and the last one is in telecode so if
if you are a visual studio user um
intellic you might have come across
intellicode it's AI powerage
um uh by code completion and support
with inside of vs code not the same as
copilot
um it looks at your uh Your solution
that you're working with and will give
you to like type support and uh and
hints around writing code for your code
base as opposed to code co-pilot which
is genericized
um like uh editors like code completion
and support actually
who who's not seen code copilot in
action who doesn't know what I'm talking
about when I'm talking about GitHub code
co-pilot
oh I can do a demo that's uh hopefully
going to steal the day most Thunder from
uh down the back are you doing co-pilot
at all this week or is mish doing it
okay sweet I'm not selling anyone's
Thunder doesn't mean I wasn't going to
do it uh so
copilot went uh GA today
um so you can it was in a um a beta you
had to get accepted for but it's now
generally available I am it's it's
called ai-powered programming so I'm
going to just make this a markdown file
mark down
uh and I've got co-pilot enabled in this
repository that's uh a tiny little
GitHub icon in the bottom right hand
corner now let's say I'm writing a blog
post about
co-pile islet
and then
it's starting to like it's giving me
help uh I'm using the markdown syntax
yes yes I am
uh let's say I'm going to write some
JavaScript
and well so we're going to do some big
JavaScript with markdown
because it knows that I'm writing
something with markdown and it's just
going to keep giving me like code help
along the way so let's say markdown Dot
there we go
render hello world
except and now I'm out of a job as
someone who does a lot of blogging
because I've just got an AI That's just
going to write by blog post for me
um so yeah AI is going to take over the
world um so like what what it's doing is
it's using um a trend air models from uh
I forget what it's called Uh but you can
look that up on the docs and it's like
cortex I think code
x uh that was going to be my second
guess codex
um and so it's uh using like inputs
probably mostly from public GitHub repos
uh but other code bases that have been
uh provided to it it's trainer model and
it will do yeah like assumptions around
the sorts of things you want
um I was actually showing uh one of my
friends who's speaking uh from OCTA uh
so C sharp
and we were doing using OCTA dot uh
octa.sdk sure
and then we're going to do a public
class
and there we go uh yep so that's how we
do a new program
uh and then let's see we're going to do
client Dot
here we go that's how we're going to get
a user
well that
Magic
um so uh so intellicode is similar to
this but it is contextualized around
your project
um it's it's available in both visual
shoe and vs code
um this copilot is available in both vs
code and visual studio as well as
jetbrain's IDs if uh that's uh that's
your preference
um but the other cool thing that you can
do with uh copilot is let's say that
we've got some code and we don't know
what it does
if I can find an editor with code so
who's ever come back to a code base you
know a couple of months later on
um man what did that do again
well with copper labs
let's select some code here to copilot
Labs here and I'm going to ask you to
explain this code
uh okay so it has created a new Cosmos
object it's created a new database
object and container and then create a
new data I mean okay cool I mean sure I
could have figured that one out but it's
it's done a reasonably good job of
explaining what that bitter code is and
that's fairly simplistic code the other
thing I could do is like uh and again I
was showing my friend from octo and
she's like well I'm a.net developer I'm
like oh okay you want this in C sharp
here's this code in C sharp
it's just it's translated that code to C
sharp um it's a bit Hit or Miss uh this
is this is still technical preview it's
just I guess more of an illustration of
concept of something that it could be
doing and it helps break down the
barriers of I've been reading an article
and it's got this um really good sample
and it's something I want to look at
iterating into our project but it's all
written in golang and I don't know
golang well
get to explain the code to me translate
that to the language that I want to work
with which I think is kind of cool
all right and
let's jump down
um to because I'm aware we've got about
10 minutes left and I want to talk a bit
about something that annoys me a lot um
or annoyed me a lot more when I was
doing consulting work and that is uh
non-standard environments like I I was
doing consulting work before I joined
Microsoft and number of times I would
turn up to a new client and they're like
okay cool um thanks for joining us for
looking forward for you to help us out
um here's the setup guide for your
machine we'll see you at the end of the
week I'm like well
it's like 100 Pages oh yeah like page 10
you've got to go ask this person over
there because that's like out of date uh
and then you get two thirds of the way
through and it hasn't worked anyway
um no matter and it's just like oh oh
yeah that's right you you need rabbitmq4
not rabbitmq3 we need to update that at
some point like who's been in that kind
of a situation you're like you started a
new job and you're just like
oh well I was going to be productive
this month but I guess not
or you've come to an open source project
and you've found a bug in it you wanna
you wanna be a good open source Citizen
and you want to contribute back your fix
so you've done your change you've
submitted a pull request and they've got
oh you didn't follow a coding guideline
what was it I didn't you read the the
markdown file I'm like which one
and then you find it there's like five
deep off the contributing guide
um like I I've that's something that
happened has happened to me on more
occasions that I care to recall uh and
it it just it frustrates me so a way
around this with vs code is using the
dev containers extension
so Dev containers allows us to set up a
remote environment using Docker on your
own local machine
so I've actually been using Dev
containers for a couple of these
projects so this is a Dev container that
I've got running here this is a react
application and a graphql server all in
one and it but it's running within uh
with inside of Docker so
um I think this is using like npm 16
whereas on my host machine I don't even
know MBM install sorry no I don't have
node installed whereas this using node
16. because I've set up this environment
that if you want to work on this project
you're going to need node 16. if I come
back to this in six months time and I've
since like and we've moved on to like
node 18 is the the default version to go
to well maybe it'll break this but this
environment is sandbox using Docker to
be that uh um to to have the things that
I want installed this particular git
repo that I've got also works with
Cosmos DB is the cosmos DB emulator so
it stands up that emulator you don't
have to install that but if you want to
have a play around with this you can
open it in the remote the dev container
and and that will set it all up entirely
with the with the cosmos emulator
running and if you don't want to use
that at the end of the day you delete
the docker images and the docker
containers and it's gone you haven't had
to uninstall software
um also with a Dev container we can
configure the extensions that should be
loaded because this particular project
you're going to be working with like
Cosmos DB and graphql and things like
that I've loaded I've configured that
I've set the dev container
which is in this dot Dev container
folder
uh to have a bunch of pre-loaded
extensions it has the docker extension
it has eslint and prettier so that
you're getting my coding standards that
I've set up for this project and you
haven't even had to like learn what they
are it's just there by default
um you'll probably want graphql tools to
work with this so we've it's got the
graphql extension in there it's called
Cosmos is an extension in there and now
anyone can pick this up and not have to
configure their environment for the way
that I want them to configure their
environment you don't have to read a
hundred page Manual of setup machine you
just kind of set it up it's just it's
just kind of set up for you
uh we've got about five minutes left um
so I'm going to do a quick view of
something that you can learn more about
uh on Friday uh and that is well let's
take this idea of an isolated
environment to the next level
and let's run it in the cloud
uh so
um this is that this is that repo um
from up on GitHub and it's like oh I've
noticed a little bug in it and I want to
come across and fix it
actually I'm just going to pop that to
it I'm just going to clone this as a new
tab so I don't lose that tab just create
a tab okay so yeah I found like a
spelling mistake in the readme file
or I want to add a readme file if I
press Dot
I end up at github.dev
um github.dev is well this is actually
vs code or it's it's a very slimmed down
version of vs code running entirely with
inside of the browser now I don't have
access to things like the terminal I
can't run an npm command or anything
like that but I can go to let's go to
say a let's go to the graphql file
that's in here
I can load that up and now I can I can
work with that now it doesn't load all
the extensions there are some extensions
will work in github.dev obviously the
graphql one doesn't but
typescript does syntax highlighting all
within the browser um and this is this
could be a more efficient way to
navigate around a code base so you want
to explore a git repo that's a GitHub
repo that someone's got you can just
poke around inside of that by opening
the files rather than you know
navigating back and forth with inside of
the browser and using the github's
built-in editor but we could go one step
further and that is with GitHub code
spaces
so there's a full session on Friday um
that uh my friend down the back Damien
from GitHub is going to be talking about
code spaces but this is an editor
entirely within the browser and it is vs
code fully running in the browser in
like a completely remote environment to
the point where I can do control
backtick to open up the terminal
um let me Zoom that in a touch more and
let's say I want to go npm run Dev
backhand so I'm going to start up the
backend web server which is by graphql
server in this particular project
so it's starting uh it's running it's
running node Bond it's compiling my
typescript
um down uh it's setting up a file system
Watcher uh because that's what gnoman's
doing there we go it's it's made it
available um it has actually found some
typescript errors that I've got with
inside of there but my API is available
at localhost 4000 slash graph API
graphql
but who's localhost like is it mine
control click on that
and now
give it a second uh it's aired out
because I think I've oh no I haven't I
haven't timed out my my login process
um that has actually tried to open up a
URL uh but I was I really should have
done npm run front end oh run Dev on the
front end
and now this will also open up uh
another so this is now running a
separate web server with inside of my
GitHub code space again same repo that I
had locally
uh and where is the there's the URL what
another localhost endpoint
there we go connect to my forwarded port
I'm hoping that it hadn't it shouldn't
have timed out the connection because
code spaces should have been offline
uh if it had timed out but come on we've
got like three minutes left and I want
this list last demo to work come on did
I sacrifice enough to the demo Gods
beforehand it stopped spinning that's
not a good sign is it
one two go no
um anyway so what uh what github's doing
is it's creating a proxy server that
sits in front of well your Local Host
hey github's down it's not my problem
uh let's give it a let's give another
reload
um yeah okay so that is
something with GitHub being down
um anyway uh Damien's doing a full code
spaces talk at the end uh on Friday so
go check that out if you want to learn
more about code spaces But ultimately
like this is a fully running Dev
environment in the cloud
um I have not had to install anything
locally for it to work um and it just
like it just works
normally
trust me on that
all right we've got about two minutes to
go so there is one final thing with
what I want to what I want to talk about
with uh
vs code
and that is something that I am way too
old to deal with and that's tick tock
did you know that vs code has a tick
tock account
they do
um tick tock.com sorry
um they have a tick tock account
um they put up videos uh constantly uh
that just show little tips and tricks
like I've been doing today of working
with vs code
um there's like some really cool things
in there
um some you know and some just
generalized you know things that you'd
find on Tick Tock where you watch this
and you're like I don't know I'm yeah I
don't understand like am I I'm too old
for this but yeah there's there's paper
cool uh like little one minute um tricks
that you can go check out on there
um and and it's yeah it's a lot of fun
um and
yeah uh if that's your if that's your
Jam at least uh so that is that is
pretty much all that I've got time for
today looking at my watch there we're
just coming up to the hour
um there is so many things that I didn't
get time to cover off today like I
didn't even show that you could
debunkode
it's an editor with a debugger in there
and I didn't even get the debug code in
it
um like you could you can use vs code as
the diff tool for like uh just within
git uh like I use that so if I'm doing
something in Visual Studio it will still
launch vs code to do my diffing because
that's the set is the the default diff
engine
um there is ways that you can customize
um the the command line to launch
different profiles with different sets
of extensions loaded on bare metal and
like more things that I could ever cover
in a one-hour session but
that is all we've got time for today
thank you for for hanging out with me
and learning well hopefully learning a
few more things to make your life even
more amazing with vs code enjoy the rest
of NDC Melbourne
[Applause]